welcome back to the Ingram angle my
interview with White House chief of
staff John Kelly continues he addresses
some recent controversies including the
removal of historic monuments and his
dispute with Democratic congresswoman
Frederica Wilson let's move on to the
Frederico wilson issue when she
overheard the conversation congresswoman
yeah the congresswoman she overheard the
conversation of the Goldstar Widow and
this blew up into a huge controversy you
came out into the press room and you
gave what was by all accounts a riveting
account of your reaction to this at the
time you said you were so upset you went
to Arlington National Cemetery can you
tell us a little bit more about that why
did you go to Arlington and what did you
do there what did you hear I would of
all the outstanding or of the things I
thought that were left in terms of
things that we hold up is special in our
country and most of them have gone by
the wayside I think I mentioned some of
them to include our flag and our anthem
those are all passe I guess but the one
thing I thought was sacrificed the
ultimate sacrifice of the nation and the
families that that bear that that that
hurt and to have seen the president make
a phone call and did the best he could
standing right next to him is she was a
nun speakerphone but to hear him talk to
for next to kin that day in essentially
the message was the same and he did the
best he could to make it personal
and the best he could to make them
understand how sorry he was as the
president and as a as a father himself
and then to see what came of that just
was stunning to me you know I made
reference to an appearance that the
congresswoman made you know 2015 yeah
and you know a number of people that
were there after she said what she said
about me
volunteered to come forward because they
saw her both before and after her
official comments I said no let's not do
this these are FBI agents former FBI
agents that were there that part of it
we should let go what did I hear over in
Arlington Cemetery some of these stones
over there represent young people that I
sent out into battle and they died not
to make it more melodramatic than it is
but my wondering was is this is any of
this worth it anymore
meaning working in the White House doing
anything for the you know is it worth it
anymore if they can if someone can can
make political hay out of something that
the president was trying to do and of
course the screams you know and a lot of
people a lot of the viewers will laugh
at this I'm sure but this screams out of
the graves was you know what are you
talking about Kelly
you know you could you got it easy look
where we are it's worth it it's worth it
to fight for America and the good news
is I think outside of this cesspool of
swamp or whatever it's called where
Americans are just doing the best they
can
working hard raising their family paying
their taxes hoping to send their kids
off to college someday that's that's
makes it all worthwhile but but it was
absolutely depressing to me to see how
that was turned into a political event I
just don't know how anyone could
possibly criticize another human being
for doing the best he or she could do to
express sorrow from the bottom of their
hearts I just it was stunning to me the
widow of LA David Johnson basically
corroborated what the congresswoman
recounted about the conversation so that
was her reaction there's also comments
that Frederica Wilson in her speech did
not brag about getting funding as you
indicated in your remarks I actually
watched Frederico Wilson Wilson speech
and she certainly used the word I a lot
and talking about how and I think we
actually have a clip of it I said I'm a
school principal and I said oh hell
we're gonna get this done I went to in
attack mode I presented it we all voted
and I dashed it over to the Senate and
put our senators on notice and guess
what the President signed the bill into
law this past Tuesday April 7 2000 go
back and talk about before her comments
and at the reception afterwards again it
was a package deal don't want to get
into it as far as the young widow goes
she has if she has every right to to say
what she wants to say but it's the it's
the politicalization of something that
was so from the heart but do you feel
like you have something to apologize do
I know no never
I'll apologize if I need to but for
something like this absolutely not I
stand by my comments what do you pray
for I pray for world peace I pray for
our society that seems to be so broken
right now and against itself I pray for
my family I pray for my son and all the
fallen I pray for a lot a prominent
Church in Alexandria Virginia where
George Washington worshiped its historic
Robert II Lake let's two-finger so this
is they decided to pull the plaques
memorializing both George Washington and
robert e lee because they want the
church to be inclusive and be considered
more tolerant what is your reaction to
that type of attempt to pull down little
markers of history well history's
history and there's certain things in
history that were not so good and other
things that were very very good I think
I think we make a mistake though and as
a society and certainly as as
individuals when we take what is today
accepted as right and wrong and go back
100 200 300 years or more and say what
those
you know what Christopher Columbus did
was wrong you know 500 years later it's
inconceivable to me that you would take
what we think now and apply it back then
I think it's just very very dangerous
and it shows you what how much of a lack
of appreciation of history and what
history is I would tell you that robert
e lee was an honorable man he was a man
that gave up gave up his country to
fight for his state which in 150 years
ago was more important than country it
was always loyalty to state first back
in those days now it's different today
but the the the lack of an ability to
compromise led to the civil war and men
and women of good faith on both sides
made their stand where their conscience
had to make their stand by pulling down
the Washington now monument so why not
read what are they going to rename it
general you know we can find some cult
hero that we can put up there and and
say well he really was the great one you
know India wore a hold of someone like
that you know but yeah Congressional
never Trump firs and you know you know
who they are Jeff Flake John McCain
they're they're resisting the Trump
agenda a lot of Italy's how do you how
do you as a white house deal with that
keep all wings of the Republican Party
together
is it possible to make so everybody
feels like they're getting a say and
this in this process so they don't feel
left out yeah as they say he talks
directly to members of Congress on both
sides of the aisle both sides of the
hill on a regular basis doesn't hesitate
to pick up the phone and call a a
Democrat and get their sense of humor I
mean you know mr. Schumer certainly he's
interacted with people like MS McCaskill
and and invites them sometimes they go
on trips mr. Donnelly from Indiana went
on a trip out to his home state he
doesn't hesitate to call he is he has
learned I don't think he'll ever accept
that politics sometimes Trump's what's
good for America
we're doing the tax cut debate not
debate but the the House and the Senate
are developing their plans doesn't he
have to get engaged though he did not
engage in Obamacare and that went down
the tubes and he's very engaged and I
think what we're about to see is is the
the the agents of the swamp are going to
start there's already amassing to stop
some of the things that the House Senate
bills have been and what the president
wants and he's going to take him on and
he's going to take this thing down to
the wire but he wants to work is working
with the Congress both sides of the of
the hill and I think there's going to be
a great tax cut come out of this but if
there isn't it won't be because they're
an if no I don't think there isn't if
that's that's a great point he will
fight tooth and nail to get what he
believes is right for the American
people relative to a tax cut and to
stimulate our economy one final question
Halloween if you could be one character
just one and what dress up is someone
general what would it be Oh a Marine
Sergeant in future men right yeah good
man thanks so much
sure appreciate hope it went well